größter wasser wo gott ist da ist jetzt
mein gott das ist jetzt so heftig
321 servus sg zu bekommen so eine
entspannte noch unter moderner games wie
spielen heute hier mit dem känguru kit
ganz entspannt school ihr wisst bescheid
wie es ist und wir haben ein neues
texture pack aufgefallen sein wir
spielen nicht nur mit dem sex weil ich
da nicht so lust auf hatte und vor allem
an laptop da nicht alles drauf hatte ich
spiele wieder meinem laptop das ist
ungefähr das größte abenteuer also dass
auch das was mich heute in der folge
meist beschäftigen wird dass ich einfach
wieder auf meinem laptop spiele ich bin
nicht mehr an maxis also nicht meinen
kranes pc sondern jetzt wieder an meinem
laptop für alle die nicht wissen wie der
etwas für laptop das ist und was er so
alles kann schaut einfach mal mein ruhm
tour video einer macht einfach schon
escape rundtour eingeben in der suche
und findet ihr das dann werdet ihr sehen
der laptop ist nicht die obergrenze so
alles kann er jo eller top sondern schon
sogar relativ alter aber er geht
eigentlich ziemlich fit finde ich
zumindest ich werde mir aber auf jeden
fall also für dafür sein alter geht
erfährt sagen wir so ich hätte mir war
auf jeden fall bei der nächsten
gelegenheit neuen pc kaufen damit ich
entweder michael somit damit einfach
richtig entspannt wieder aufnehmen kann
wenn mit dem laptop ist es immer so ein
bisschen stressig ich habe jetzt auch
dieses texture pack drin muss damit ein
bisschen flüssiger spielen kann hier
weil das mit dem 128 dass er vorhatte
nicht so gut geht
ich muss ja auch mal dass textfenster
kleiner machen die drei habe ich jetzt
mal auflage gemacht weil er damit bei
max auch aber irgendwie ist dieses
textfenster riesig groß egal wir droppen
auf denen drauf hier soll
ok
seltsam fand wieder die all blacks kanal
wird weil ich finde dieses texture pack
ziemlich cool was wir das spiel ich weiß
gar nicht mehr genau wie es heißt könnte
mal kurz nach schauen das ist riskant
auf jeden fall das bleibe ich erstmal
hier schon die flaschen mit ihr leben
was entscheiden können so herausspringen
können nach können wir können wir hallo
können wir sehr gut funktioniert alles
klar so der nächste ist bisschen weiter
entfernt alles klar da kann man erstmal
entspannt hier unser brot kräften sich
danach schauen wir leider keine rüstung
aber der bogen immerhin einen schönen
bogen kräften und da man damit ihr dann
die leute auseinander nehmen weil bogen
passt alles nehmen dass hier mit und
dann schauen wir mal weiter
also leute hat mir auf jeden fall jetzt
einen neuen pc bestellen
das wird auch ein bisschen größere
investition das ist einfach so als ich
meine für so ein pc mit dem man richtig
gut aufnehmen kann mal wenn man schon
mal eingestellt und will mir auch keinen
kein scheiß teil sondern sagen wir so
was ordentliches was auch wirklich was
kann was auch eine deutliche
verbesserung darstellt muss man einfach
schon mal 1000 euro investieren es ist
einfach so + monitor plus softbox also
das wird ordentlich da muss ich ganz
schön tief in die tasche greifen aber
gut zack und trotz leicht ruckeligen
bild verteilen wir hier die hits wie ein
weltmeister sensationell wenn man das
mal so sagen
da haben wir alles klar sehr gut der
andere ist da kommt er auf uns ich weiß
es nicht
ja er kommt auf uns aber schauen wir was
er machen was mit dem machen ich würde
sagen ein paar bauditz sagt der erste
für mich ist jetzt eine krasse
umstellung müsst ihr wissen
ich bin nicht nur umgestellt durch den
muss ich nicht nur auf einen neuen pc
umstellen der zugegebenermaßen bisschen
ruckeln ich hoffe ihr verzeiht mir das
also ich werde mir so bald wie möglich
diesen neuen pc bestellen
dann können wir da richtig flüssig
aufnehmen solange hoffe ich dass ich mir
verzeihen
das ist jetzt ein wenig ruckelt aber ich
meine so dramatisch ist es auch nicht
machen
einen schönen helm des offenen luxus
wenn man sie einfach in die hell machen
kann das einfach luxus so muss das sein
was wollte ich sagen das habe ich habe
ich selbst vergessen
die stacks fans irritiert ein bisschen
muss ich sagen
seitdem haben ja alles klar dieses
textes ist groß ich da gab es ja
irgendwie trinke man das kleiner macht
oder wissen was wisst ihr noch immer
dieses textfenster kleiner mache ich mir
ziemlich gerade nicht mehr ein ich weiß
dass es da so was gab es schön
regenerationstag der nächste ist
bisschen weiter entfernt ist natürlich
jetzt schlecht weil ich die marotte habt
die übel angewohnheit hier immer den
kompost spam das werde ich jetzt mal
überlassen damit der bildschirm ich ganz
voll wird das entscheidet die ja und
eine heilung regenerations- dann kommen
wir auch mehr als voll in das du
eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich ziemlich
gut
schauen wir einfach mal was ich damit
jetzt so bewegen lässt würde ich mal
sagen ich habe alles diese bisschen
umgestellt ich habe jetzt unter anderem
auch ein stativ habe meine face com
nicht auf den bücherstadt bestehens fand
ich ziemlich cool dieses stativ hat mir
max ausgeliehen größeren dich gegeben
keine ahnung wer braucht und jetzt ja
sehr gut wir haben ihn wir haben ihn wir
haben ihn und jetzt fest der aktionstag
rein weil dann jetzt arbeiten
regeneration 2 für eine minute jetzt
müssen schnell die anderen suchen schon
wieder tut mir leid tut mir leid
wir müssen jetzt den anderen suchen sagt
er ist er
euro
aber in schweigen
er sei es ist hier das ist eigentlich
ein handicap und sagen mit den apps die
auf die oft einfach ein handicap
beispiel mit 15 fps 20 erfährst du zecke
pro fall schreiben ja wir haben es
geschafft leute wir haben es geschafft
das gibt es nicht dass gibt es echt
nicht wir haben es einfach geschafft mit
diesen okay jetzt mit 620 jetzt schauen
wir zwölf ps auch einfach mal zwölf fps
aber mit diesen zwölf fps endrunde ende
games zu gewinnen das ist ja mal richtig
richtig schick und ich würde sagen wir
hängen einfach noch eine runde klicks
sowie games hinten dran wo ich habe mich
jetzt doch umentschieden wir spielen
nicht auf team wie erwartet sondern hier
auf einer map die das schloss heißt die
spieler zum ersten mal das problem noch
mal aus und wir haben keine schlagwaffe
das ist sehr gefährlich
sehr sehr gefährlich gefundenes fressen
für jeden upgraden will aber mein gott
das ist jetzt so heftig krass so ok hier
sind offen ich glaube mir ein achtfaches
nicht können türen schließen entspannen
und zwar ein bisschen bisschen
runterkommen bisschen einfach mal so den
geist beruhigen damit man gerade einfach
zu hektisch hab's gesehen ist es einfach
ein krasses handicap will ich sagen es
war ein krasses handicap warf sie ist
nicht cool nicht korrekt macht das
lieber nicht
dies schreiben ist
unfreundlich respektlos aber jetzt gehen
wir aus jetzt muss ein mir egal jetzt
wer wo wie hier endlich alles schon gut
klar dass jetzt eine keine chance hatte
keine chance das war viel zu heftig das
ist einfach echt brutal na ja gut aber
ich habe wie gesagt demnächst vielleicht
sogar heute noch diesen pc bestellen
dann läuft alles demnächst mal wieder
keinen grund sich sorgen zu machen
werden heute auf jeden fall eine lustige
handygames folge mit ja ein bisschen ein
bisschen skill ein bisschen kind und ein
bisschen low framerate aber an sich ist
es eigentlich auch ein legitimes
handicap für nicht ganz ganz ganz cool
so aber würde ich sagen einfach könnt
gerne einen leiter lassen man sich
gefallen ist können die kommentare
schreiben
was eure idee ist für die nächste
handicap in folge könnten wir auch gerne
und das recht in die kommentare
schreiben wo man so pc bestellen kann wo
das günstig es sich lohnt wo habt ihr
gute erfahrung gemacht würde ich sagen
sie jetzt nichts video wieder hat loach